One of our writers, Karen,
is 24 years old.
To give you an idea
of how young that is,
the same year I joined
the cast of "SNL,"
Karen joined a taekwondo class
for first graders.
As a result,
she has a much different
frame of reference
than a lot of us.
So we thought we'd find ou
exactly what Karen knows
about the past in a segmen
called "What Does Karen Know?"
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey.
-Welcome back, Karen.
-Hi. Yeah.
-I always enjoy this so much
I'm going to show you a photo,
and you're going to try
to tell us what or who it is
-Okay.
-Are you ready?
-I'm ready.
-Okay.
-[ Gasps ] Oh. Um...
Okay.
It's a person who dressed up
to look like the thing he won.
A costume for Halloween?
-You think -- No, it was not -
This is -- This is --
I'll give you
the first two initials.
-Okay.
-M.C.
-Hammer.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He -- He designed
his own line of pants.
Those are called Hammer pants.
-Okay.
-And he was a forerunner of th
#MeToo movement because he was
very insistent that
you should not touch this.
-I see what you did.
And I like it.
-You like it.
-Yeah, that was cool.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God. Okay.
It's clearly called My Buddy
-Okay.
-And it couldn't --
-Good job, guys.
-Oh, is it actually called
My Buddy?
-Yeah.
-Is it a haunted doll?
-No.
This is actually supposed to b
a friendly toy
that you would play with.
-Oh.
-And, yeah, it had a song.
It was on -- There were
commercials all the time.
♪♪ My buddy, my buddy ♪♪
♪♪ Wherever he goes,
I'm gonna go ♪♪
Or something like that.
I don't know.
But, yeah,
but then they had to --
They recalled it because
it kept murdering people.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you have one?
-I didn't have a My Buddy.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Um...
-That's too bad.
-Yeah. I mean, I asked.
[ Laughter ]
What's that?
-Oh. Well, it's not what
I initially thought it was
-Well, instead -- "Karen
After Dark," we're gonna -
-Okay. It's something to mak
your inner thighs stronger
-Yes! Now, what would you
call a product
that makes your inner thighs
stronger?
-Stronger Thighs!
Thigh Man.
-Thigh Man is very close.
-Oh.
-Thigh -- First two letter
of that are right.
Thigh M-A...
-Thigh Madam?
-Thigh. Thigh...
-Thigh mas...
-Master?
-Yeah!
-Wow.
-Very good.
-I got it.
-And the key to the Thigh Master
was you had to use it
in an all-white room
with a white chair.
-Very cool, very cool.
Who dat?
-Um, uh, somebody
who did a bad thing.
But also depending on how
this photo was taken,
maybe he was married?
-Married?
-In case it was like a flip --
It's his wedding ring?
Never mind. Forget I said it
-All right.
So, you know how this is -
So this doesn't mean
anything to you?
-Um, I mean, no.
-Okay.
-In the '90s, this person wa
known by 75% of all Americans.
Isn't that crazy?
-George W. Bush.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry. '90s.
George H.W. Bush.
-Yeah.
-Yes. Thank you.
-Right. No, yeah. That's right
So you know how sometimes
you have a house guest
and they're really irritating?
-Yes.
-Well, sometimes you're th
house guest and the people
you're staying with
are the problem.
-Did he murder somebody?
-No, he's --
His name was Kato Kaelin.
And he -- he was a house guest
for a football player.
-Oh.
-And that's all you need to know
because, uh...
I feel like
there are certain things
your generation
doesn't need to hear about
-Okay.
-All right. Is it my turn?
-Yes, it's your turn.
-Okay.
-I'm going to show you stuff
that you haven't seen.
-There you go. Or maybe I have
I'm cool and young.
-Um, okay.
I just forgot.
You sign my paychecks.
You're so cool, so young.
Okay. Do you know what this is
-Well, those are sneakers.
-Yes.
-Oh, but they have
that roller thing.
So they're, like, skate shoes?
-Yeah! Do you know
what they're called?
-Um, Thigh Masters.
-Yes!
They're called Heelys.
-Heelys.
-Yeah.
-Oh, that's really cool. Yeah.
-They're really awesome.
-Were you good?
Did you have a pair of Heelys?
-I did have a pair of Heelys
I really wanted them
in first grade.
And my parents made me wai
until I was in second grade,
because I was very small
for my size.
-But it seems to me Heelys would
be better if you were small,
'cause then if you fell down
you'd be closer to the ground.
-Oh. That's actually
a really good point.
-I'd be a better parent
than your parents.
-Yeah, that's fair.
Okay, the next one is --
Do you know who that is?
-Um --
-Wow. They know.
-People know.
I mean, I -- You know, I -
I mean, I don't know
the context of this.
I'm going to assume
it's a penguin.
I mean, I know that much.
-Yes, absolutely.
-I don't know why -- Yeah.
-Why he's there.
-Why you would need
to have this.
-Okay. First off,
because it's awesome.
-Okay. Is it a toy?
-I actually don't think
they ever made merch for it.
But basically it's part of thi
website called Club Penguin.
-Okay.
-And you can go on and hang out.
And you can have
your own penguin
and then play a lot of games
and then chat with strangers
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-So it seems like
a gateway to abduction?
-Yeah! That's pretty much it
-And what's his name?
What's this penguin's name
-Well, you get to name
your own penguin.
-Gotcha. Did you do this?
-I did, yeah.
-What was your penguin's name?
-Mine was supposed to be Margot.
But I forgot the "R",
so it was just Magot.
And I couldn't change it.
-And what grade were you i
when you were rocking Magot?
-Well, I was too old.
I was in, like, eighth grade
[ Laughter ]
-So you were on wheelies,
being a cool-ass dude
when you were in second grade.
-Yes.
-And then you just plummeted
-I truly -- Yeah, I peaked
I also skateboarded
in fourth grade.
-Oh, my gosh.
So you were like,
active, active,
virtual penguins.
-Yeah.
-Thank you so much.
That's Karen, everybody.
This has been
"What Does Karen Know?"